nous sommes sereins nous aussi parce que
nous pensons que véritablement si nous
proposons une réforme dont on sait
qu'elle peut être difficile à accepter
pour certains
c'est pour faire que nous puissions
maintenir notre système de répartition à
l'équilibre et quand on sait que nous
avons de moins en moins de cotisants et
des retraites qui durent de plus en plus
longtemps si nous le prenons pas nos
responsabilités ce sont les générations
futures qui paieront la note et qui la
paieront beaucoup plus cher il nous
appartient et vous le savez
de poursuivre le débat nos concitoyens
l'attendent ce débat en ce qui concerne
effectivement ces inégalités ces
inégalités qu'il y a dans la vie
professionnelle ces inégalités qui se
déclinent également dans le système de
retraite et nous constituants sont
impatients ils nous l'ont dit que leur
en propose que leur propose
qu'on leur propose des mesures qui
prennent en compte ces inégalités
qui prennent en compte l'usure
professionnelle qui prennent en compte
les maires de famille ça fait déjà
plus de trois jours que nous siègeons où
nous avons entendu nombre de discours
tout à fait justifié et il nous
appartient maintenant de passer à l'acte
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
donnons un avis défavorable pour
retourner en commission faire le travail
que nous avons déjà largement fait
[Musique]